the ending of Disney's Haunted Mansion
features a lot of goals and too many
dancing ghosts but it also has fans
wondering there's a potential sequel in
the works if the ending is any clue we
may already have our answer
before we jump into the film's ending
let's do a little recap of everything
that leads to the big finale one single
mother Gabby and her son Travis enter
the Mansion they become haunted by
various ghosts so they call on some
experts including a psychic named
Harriet and a paranormal photographer
named Ben not afraid of a couple goals
together the group tries to uncover the
truth behind the mansion and the
particularly treacherous being known as
the hatchbox ghost they eventually
discover that the hubbox ghost is
formerly Aleister Crump a socialite who
secretly murdered many people until he
was beheaded by his detractors as the
hatchbox ghost Alastair has been
collecting souls in the Mansion for
decades he hopes to reach one thousand
Souls so that he can come back to the
world of living once a group learns that
Alistair is only one solar way and is
targeting both Ben and Travis due to
their lingering grief they're forced to
find something that belonged to him once
a group has the belonging Harriet can
perform a banishing spell with Madame
Leota unfortunately alistair's got
plenty of tricks up his sleeve
Alistair can't use any old soul to
complete his plan it needs to come from
a willing volunteer this is why he
targets Ben and Travis they're both
still dealing with the unresolved
feelings over the death of loved ones so
they're vulnerable to alistair's tracks
Travis nearly does when Alistair mimics
his father's voice but Ben intervenes
and stops it however this doesn't stop
Alistair from attempting to Coke span as
a result Ben is forced to make a crucial
choice either sacrifice himself to save
everyone else or let alistair's reign of
terror continue from there Alistair
transports Ben Travis and Gabby to a
graveyard in the graveyard Alistair
reminds Ben that he will never be over
Alyssa's death and not giving up his
soul will be the only way to see her
again however Ben doesn't succumb to
alistair's tricks and with the help of
his new friends he defeats Alistair by
kicking him into the Open Grave below
with A New Perspective Ben has finally
come to terms with Alyssa's death and is
able to move forward in life
once Alistair is defeated Ben and Travis
helped fulfill the Sea Captain's ghost
Final West to be brought back to the Sea
after that Ben gives away Alyssa's
belongings and prepares to start a new
chapter in his life however before he
leaves he spots a cat sitting on the
porch with the name Tater Tot on its
color the name is tied to a story been
told about Alyssa's love of unhealthy
food so it's a reminder of Alyssa when
the film ends everyone reunited the
Mansion for a Halloween party and even
the spirits get down on some singing and
dancing
but they're running themes and Haunted
Mansion are about grief and how people
live on in memory Ben in particular is
played by grief over Alyssa's death
which affects him throughout the film in
a deeply heartfelt and emotional scene
Ben talks to the group about how
Alyssa's death still haunts him he even
nearly breaks down in tears while
talking about not knowing whether or not
Alyssa knew he loved her that
uncertainty is a core reason behind his
continual suffering meanwhile Harriet is
reminded of a lost loved one by the
sounds of train whistles seeing as they
both loved model trains he tells Ben
that he too will find something to
fondly remember Alyssa by which will
help him move on for Ben this is a cat
tater's Hut Ben's Ark in Haunted Mansion
is meant to remind viewers that even
when someone is gone their memory still
lives on in other ways so the biggest
takeaway from the ending of the film is
that people can overcome grief without
forgetting the person they've lost
once Alistair has pulled back into the
ground most viewers probably assume that
the rest of the spirits would simply
disappear and move on after all Alistair
was the main thing keeping them in the
Mansion however instead of Vanishing the
ghosts moved back into the mansion and
began celebrating alistair's demise
Alistair might have been the reason why
the ghosts were haunting everyone in the
Mansion but he's not to blame for why
they haven't been able to move on like
the sea captain ghost every spirit that
remains on the Mansion still has
something they're holding on to in the
real world which is preventing them from
going into the Afterlife as Harriet
explains every soul will be caught in a
sort of limbo Ghost World if they leave
the world of the living with regrets or
unresolved baggage so while they would
understandably want to party in the
Mansion after Alastair is dealt with
there's still some unresolved aspects in
their stories this is why they can't
leave you these ghosts they're running
from something
despite the fact that Disney is always
trying to turn their new films into
franchises Haunted Mansion features an
ending that pretty much closes the book
on the story the end of the film doesn't
tease any potential for Ben and the
others to return nor away for the ghost
of the Mansion to have their stories
fleshed out so it seems like Haunted
Mansion could be a one and done story
for Disney which is a rarity in
Hollywood nowadays however there are
still some avenues for a potential
sequel a sequel could easily see Ben and
the group deal with a different Haunted
Mansion or even become acquainted with
some of the ghosts still lurking around
the original Mansion given the mansion's
murder-filled history there could even
be a new antagonist that rises up that
antagonist may even be able to acquire
the power that eluded Alistair obviously
a strong box office performance and
positive critical reception could entice
his need to do more movies in this world
however with Disney CEO Bob iger's
recent comments about downsizing some of
the company's established franchises
it's probably more likely that this will
be the only Haunted Mansion movie for
quite a while
wow you just did that just now
although there hasn't been an
announcement of a sequel to Haunted
Mansion director Justin Simeon has
stated that the door is open for more
stories in this world while talking with
sfx magazine Simeon mentioned that he
believes the film's World building
creates tons of potential for a sequel
he told the outlet it's definitely in
the realm of possibility Simeon also
said that a lot of thought went into
fleshing out the world that the movie
takes place in before adding it was
really just about expanding what we know
and what we can see around the story
just a bit further but not filling in
every blank you then went on to say we
certainly set up a lot that I think a
lot of other stories could derive from
and continue from not really up to me
but I definitely think there are
possibilities there Simeon went even
further in talking about other film's
depiction of the hatbox ghosts can be
applied to other goals within the story
he told sfx were pulling from what has
been established what really has been
rumored and tried to flesh him out and
flesh that story out too I think it's
really satisfying but it also leaves the
door open for a lot more while the
decision lied to the higher ups the
director clearly sees potential for
Haunted Mansion to be further explored
even if a direct sequel doesn't happen
there are other ways that Disney could
continue the story of these characters
and this world for example there could
be spin-off films focusing on the
stories of the various ghosts kind of
like what the conjuring Universe does
with its spooky characters Disney could
even make a villain focused origin movie
for the hapbox ghost just like they did
with Maleficent and Cruella and if they
wanted an alternative to the big screen
in order to keep costs down Disney plus
would be a great place for Haunted
Mansion content moreover an animated
series focusing on the film's characters
and ghosts could be an absolute blast
and deliver some family-friendly horror
that audiences of all ages would enjoy
another Haunted Mansion crossover could
also be worth looking into after all it
already happened not too long ago with
Muppets Haunted Mansion which most
critics loved imagine how fun it would
be to see Mickey Mouse or other Disney
characters going through their own
terrifying journey in the Haunted
Mansion franchise frankly it sounds like
a perfect recurring Halloween special
for the streamer another great idea is
an anthology series based on the ghost
of the Mansion where the new goals pass
fleshed out every week in a new episode
yes Works around every corner
haunted mountain is far from being the
first of Disney's theme park rides to
get its own movie and it definitely
won't be the last along with a sea
quarter 2021's Jungle Cruise Disney is
set to develop more parts of the
Caribbean movies as well as movies based
on rides like a Big Thunder Mountain
Railroad and Space Mountain while it's
clear that Disney isn't pumping the
brakes on trying to bring their most
famous rise onto the big screen the lack
of franchise building and the ending of
Haunted Mansion could be a sign that
accompanies other ride inspired movies
might also just be one-offs aside from
Pirates of the Caribbean none of
Disney's ride adaptations have been
successful enough or garnered a beginner
fan base to keep them afloat for
multiple pictures if Haunted Mansion
does well maybe that would change
however the ending of Haunted Mansion
makes it pretty obvious that Disney
doesn't intend on churning up multiple
movies unless I determine there's an
appetite for them so the upcoming Big
Thunder Mountain Railroad and Space
Mountain films as well as other ride
adaptations Disney decides to make in
the future will likely be Standalone
Adventures
as mentioned earlier the idea of other
franchises crossing over with the
Haunted Mansion isn't all that strange
since it happened not too long ago from
Mickey and his friends having an
animated horror adventure to Marvel
characters taking a trip to the iconic
horror site there are plenty of cool
crossovers that would be incredible to
see but you know what would be a really
amazing crossover one with Disney's 2003
Haunted Mansion movie while it would be
tough to believe that these movies take
place in the same world there's surely a
storyline that could bring these two
universes together the idea of seeing
that Keith Stanfield who plays Ben in
the 2023 film and Eddie Murphy on the
big screen together sounds like an
absolute treat top Spirits ain't no dark
Spirit don't you make no dark spirits
come out sure it's a wildly ambitious
task but it's something that Disney
could certainly make happen and it's
just one of the many potential
crossovers that could make the Haunted
Mansion franchise something truly
special